So
Oh Mann
Geiler Scheiß er war ja was der kacke er
Am start
Oh
So und sie bait largo an sein
Und
naja gut also ich habe jetzt alles entfernt was ich entfernen kann ja ich
habe die ich habe die clips weggemacht
ja normalerweise mache ich keine ich mache keine links auf ne aber in diesem
fall dachte ich mir so einfach das klingt das klingt nicht gefährlich und
bär war es irgendwie so eine oh man jebaited ich krass jebaited
sollte man den typ nicht bannen ich habe den gebannt
normalerweise mache ich keine links auf irgendwie ich weiß nicht diesmal habe
ich nicht dran nachgemacht das klingt nicht gefährlich bär in your face
gibt es gibt es einen gibt es ein plugin
stream filter chrome
oh nein es gibt kennst du monogame ja das muss man nachher angucken das
vielleicht nicht schlecht dass er ganze misst dass gar nicht im stream aufgehen
kann machen wir mal settings history clear nicht dass ich aus versehen beim
sinnlose rum tippen
auch den kram noch mal aufmach hoffentlich kein bann naja also ich
meine es war ja absolut unbeabsichtigt und ich meine ich habe alles entfernt
was ich machen konnte ja ich habe das wort weggeschmissen ich habe alle clips
entfernt dies dies gibt
gibt auch sonst keine mehr also
so
ok also wo sind wir stehen geblieben amazon amazon
schau mal auf github nach folgenden haus tanker stars das ist nice ist es
eine plek ist es eine pleite list pleite list
das da oder das stream wird abgekackt ist ja
so
das ist ganz cool kann man das kann man das in new block verwenden
so ich gucke mir das mal an also es wird stehen echt ganz praktisch
wenn selbst wenn ich mal grad nicht dran denke irgendwelche links nicht aufzumachen
dass dann wenigstens die sache gleich geblockt wird oder ich könnte ich
könnte auch über mein über mein dings pie gehen über mein was ist mit dem
stream hier los voll voll im arsch
na wie heißt pie hole pie pie hole jetzt habe ich kann man die liste vielleicht
auch eintragen
so
monitor halterung
hier wie nix dabei
an
Smartwatches ist auch so was, wo ich den Sinn nicht drin sehe, außer
Außer man verwendet das Ding irgendwie so als Sporttracker oder so
Ja dann verstehe ich
Aber ansonsten hält sich finde ich sehr in Grenzen
Was man mit so einer Smartwatch machen kann
Hast du eigentlich aktuell eine Beziehung? Nein, habe ich nicht
Auch keine Internetgrills am Start
Wobei ich sag's euch Internetgrills mache ich nie im Leben mehr
nie mehr
Die meisten Mädels also die die ist da vor allem online dann
Hi hi hi und naja
Hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal irgendwie erlebt das kannst du so knicken
Die haben alle einander waffeln die sind alle immer ganz dicht
Und ich sage jetzt nicht alle Mädels sondern diese MMO online
Hi hi lull
Nasenspide Mädels oder die da hier die hier hi hi das sind die schlimmsten
Glaubt mir wenn ihr mal sowas lest leute nehmt reis aus
das das in kombination ist
der teufel das wollt ihr nicht da spreche ich aus erfahrung
Ja und das mache ich nie mehr mache ich nie wieder
Ich wusste dass jetzt im chat eine ankommt diesen komischen nasenspide und weil ich weiß nicht was die Mädels heute online schreiben ja
Damals den MMOs haben die haben die Mädels immer so gesort den den hier gemacht dann haben sie auch immer
haben immer hi hi und sowas ey schlimm
Ich habe schon ein paar Mädels online
nennen wir es mal kennengelernt aber
das hat sich nie
in echt auch nur ansatzweise so widergespiegelt wie man sich das vorher
vielleicht erhofft hat
das war immer komplett für ein Arsch
komplett
ja und die krönung war mal eine
das kann ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht erzählen
aber das weiß ja keiner um wen es geht
die krönung war mal eine
das ist aber schon ein paar jahre her
die erzählt hat sie ist irgendwie 21
oder ich sag jetzt nicht woher sie kommt ja
ist 21 und
im endeffekt war sie verheiratet mit 31
online Mädels leute lasst sein
das ist nicht
das ist für eure nerven nicht gut
das ist wirklich nicht gut
ja egal
sei doch froh dass es wirklich eine Frau war
das ist das ist eine sache da bin ich mir bei den allen sicher
dass es eine Frau war
aber das hat es im prinzip auch nicht besser gemacht
ist ja wenn es dann
also es spricht ja nichts dagegen
es spricht ja überhaupt nichts dagegen
wenn man online leute kennen dann
ich mein wir sind im jahr 2008
da ist ja überhaupt nichts dagegen zu sagen
das wichtige ist
und
das kann man eigentlich durch die bank weg sagen
egal wo wenn man online einen kennenlernen
selbst wenn der nicht aus der nähe kommt
ist vollkommen egal
man sollte gucken dass wenn man sich gut versteht
und irgendwie auch so beidseitig das interesse besteht
dass man sich trifft
es hat keinen sinn
und wie gesagt da spreche ich leider aus erfahrung
wenn man irgendwie ein halbes jahr
oder so online irgendwie da rum
und ja
was man da halt online so treibt
und sich dann trifft und feststellt
man kann sich überhaupt nicht ab offline
das hat wirklich keinen sinn das ist
komplett verschenkte zeit
und ihr merkt das daran
das muss ich aufpassen dass hier nicht gleich wieder
die feministen am start sind
oder so
was wollte ich jetzt sagen
ja ihr merkt das daran
wenn irgendwas nicht stimmt
dass
wenn man sich online kennen gelernt hat
ganz gut versteht und sagt ja lass mal
irgendwie und von beiden
seiten bekundet interesse besteht
an so einer geschichte ja
wenn dann immer versucht
wird irgendwelche ausreden zu finden
warum das mit dem treffen nicht funktioniert
also
so nach dem motto man ist sich eigentlich einig
ja mal gucken und so
lass uns doch mal irgendwie treffen
nee was weiß ich
mein
und muss
in die Tierklinik
oder ja dann können wir nächste Woche
nee nächste Woche hat meine
Oma Geburtstag ja keine Ahnung
ein paar Tage später nee das geht auch nicht
und wenn das so anfängt da ist
irgendwas faul
da ist
da stimmt irgendwas nicht wenn das so anfängt
ja
das absolute minimum sind
Videochats mit ja gut
das redet euch letztendlich auch nirgends davor
es ist was
komplett anderes ob du quasi mit
Leuten laberst ob du weißt wie die aussehen
selbst wenn du irgendwie
mit webcam
laberst es ist komplett
anders wenn du den Leuten mal komplett
wirklich in echt gegenüberstehst
und
deswegen ist das auch wichtig
wenn beide seite wollen
dass man dann guckt ob das prinzipiell
funktioniert ja
muss ja nicht RL gleich über sich herfallen
oder so das wird ja bei wenigsten instant passieren
aber zumindest mal gucken
ob man auch in echt halbwegs miteinander auskommt
und wenn von beiden seiten Interessen besteht
und immer wieder
irgendwelche fadenscheinigen Ausreden
dazwischen kommen
da stimmt irgendwas nicht
und da ist es eigentlich das beste
gleich zu sagen Leute lasst bleiben
das ist
sonst nur sinnlose psychische Belastung
die man nicht braucht
ja das ist auch nicht schlecht
ich mein es kann auch funktionieren
aber mir ist nie was
gescheites bei rausgekommen
zumindest nichts wirklich längerfristiges
bei online
Bekanntschaften
damals war das war
als ich auch da auch gespielt hab war das ja ganz schlimm
da hab ich sogar extra so ein richtig
ein richtiges Schleimefoto von mir hochgeladen
auf so einer seite wo man
Bilder scheren konnte von
wo die Leute die quasi das MMO
gespielt haben halt ihre
Bilder von sich geschert haben da hab ich extra
so ein richtiges Schleimefoto hochgeladen
so mit Schleim Frisur
und gegeld und so
also
allein aus dem Grund
dass die weibliche Bevölkerung des Servers wusste
wie geil ich ausschau damals
das ist übrigens bescheuert
was auch nicht was geil ich so war ja
aber ich hatte halt ein Foto in dem Style
so nach dem Motto so alter sieht das geil aus
ja da war ich
ja und deswegen kann ich sagen
das ist keine gute Idee
die Webseite gibt es nicht mehr
dieses Foto
könnte ich euch sogar zeigen
wenn ich es irgendwo finden würde
weil
damals hatte ich ja sogar noch
damals hatte ich ja sogar noch komplett überall Haare
auf dem Kopf
also ich sehe
nicht mehr allsatzweise so aus wie
auf dem Foto
vom Gesicht erkennt man einen schon
aber
ich habe weder noch so eine Schleime Frisur
noch sehe ich aus
wie irgendwie 19
ne ich habs nicht
ich habs nicht ich würde es euch sogar zeigen
ich würde es euch sogar zeigen
weil daran erkennt man mich wirklich nicht
so
so wie für einmal der 1940
ich muss demnächst auch mal was
fuddern
Übelst Hunger
Jetzt such mal raus ne
Weiß gar nicht wo ich das hab
Und schon was gefunden bei Amazon
Nee ist irgendwie nix dabei. Was soll denn das sein? Sieht aus wie ein Kran oder?
Professioneller Kopfhörerständer
Also, jetzt war ganz im Ernst. Meint ihr das ein professioneller Ständer irgendeiner Art so aussieht?
Ernsthaft ja
Alter, wenn irgendwie einer heute noch Pornseiten postet, werdet ihr instant gebannt, ich sag's nur mal
Wir bannen, wir bannen ihn jetzt nicht, aber, ähm, ich sag's nur noch mal, wenn heute noch einer irgendwie so ne Scheiße postet ist instant ban
Das sieht wirklich fast aus wie ein Kran, vor allem wie ein sehr billiger Kran. Irgendein Kran auf dem ich nix platzieren will
Kann man mal auf Twitter kurz gucken
Oh Leute, ich würd mich so freuen, ich würd mich so freuen, wenn wirklich dieses Jahr Bad Company angekündigt würde
Das wär vorher wieder eingefallen. Ich war vorher kurz davor Battlefield 5 zu installieren, weil's mir irgendwie keinen großartigen Bock macht
Das wär echt das Geilste. Bad Company Immortal, ja, genau, Smartphone, Smartphone Game
Am besten war dieser April-Scherz-Typ auf der BlizzCon. Und wie ernst die dann auf der Bühne auch geantwortet haben
So nach dem Motto, ey Leute, ist das hier ein April-Scherz oder was? Nein, es handelt sich hier um ein volles Feature Diablo Mobile Game
Es hätte bloß noch gefehlt, dass er gesagt hätte, wir haben auf unsere Community gehört und eure Stimme war klar, ihr wollt ein mobiles Diablo haben
Und es wäre überhaupt nicht dazu gekommen, dass die Leute sich darüber lustig gemacht hätten oder sich darüber aufgeregt hätten
Hätten sie den letzten Teaser dazu verwendet, Diablo 4 zu teasern. Also die letzten 30 Sekunden hätten sie sagen müssen
Einfach so nach dem Motto, ja, und während ich rausgehe, wollte ich euch noch was zeigen, so nach dem Motto
Und dann läuft 30 Sekunden Diablo 4 Teaser oder irgendwas und gut wär gewesen
So haben die das mit Elder Scrolls 6 auch gemacht. Der Elder Scrolls 6 Trailer, wir haben uns den hier ja schon angeguckt
Den kannst du nicht mal Trailer, nicht mal Teaser, das ist nichts, das ist ein Trailer, den dir einer in einer halben Stunde After Effects zusammenbaut
Also gar nichts
Aber die Leute sind ausgeflippt
Braucht man alles irgendwie nicht, irgendwie ist bei Amazon nichts dabei, oder?
Habt ihr schon bei Amazon heute was gekauft?
Was hältst du von Windows Subsystem vor Linux?
Äh, ist gut, Microsoft geht da auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung
Katschi Bettwäsche, Dashcam
Ist die Dinger wasserdicht? Eher nicht, oder?
Vielleicht kann man die nämlich als Outdoor-Kamera verwenden
Am Hoftor oder so, anstatt, ne die sind da wahrscheinlich nicht IP, was ist das, IP67 oder so, Spritzwasser geschützt
Ja das könnte schon sein, das könnte tatsächlich sein, dass Diablo 3 mobile übelst gut wird
Aber das wollten die Leute halt nicht hören
Und verständlich, ich mein überleg doch mal wer geht denn auf die BlizzCon
Ich mein das sind Leute, die ähm, das sind Leute die teilweise aus anderen Ländern kommen, die kaufen sich ein BlizzCon Ticket
Die bezahlen den Aufenthalt dort, die bezahlen das Hotel, die Übernachtung alles und die bezahlen die Hinreise
Also sprich, das sind Leute die geben irgendwie was weiß ich in Chaos oder so, um auf die BlizzCon zu gehen, 1000 Euro
Oder vielleicht sogar mehr, keine Ahnung, aber zumindest ordentlich Geld, um auf die BlizzCon zu gehen
Und was da sitzt sind quasi, das sind die Hardcore-Blizzard-Fans
Und die spielen nicht zum größten Teil auf dem Handy oder auf dem Smartphone
Oder wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zum größten Teil auf der Konsole
Und das heißt, vor solchen Leuten präsentierst du dann dein Diablo 3 mobile
Da musst du dich doch nicht wundern
Geht's doch, nein geh ich nicht hin
Luke Jam
Wann ist das immer Weihnachten oder Silvester? Silvester, ne?
Das ist ja jedes Jahr im gleichen Termin
Gehst du hin? Ah, du gehst hin, ok
Gehst du nur hin oder hältst du einen Vortrag?
Wahrscheinlich gehst du nur hin, oder?
27 bis 30, ach stimmt, ja das ist immer so in dem Dreh
Immer zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester
Professionell ist ein Gaming-Mousepad, es ist irgendwie nichts dabei
Gar nichts dabei
Deine Meinung zu den reduzierten LG-Fernsehern? Ich habe mich null mit beschäftigt
Also ich habe mir die weder im Stream angeguckt, noch habe ich Erfahrungen mit LG-Fernsehern
Das Sport-Armband-Handy, ja das gibt es auch schon viel
Was denn das? Sieht aus wie so ein Stelzbomber
Sieht ja fast so schlimm aus wie diese Netgear Stelzbomber-Router
Warum müssen Router so aussehen?
Für mich sehen Router viereckig aus, ohne RGBs und dafür mit guten Features
Ich habe übelst Hunger
Muss was essen
Ist das ein Koffer oder ist das ein Lautsprecher?
Aha das ist ein Lautsprecher, ok
Was hältst du von einem Beamer im Wohnzimmer statt TV?
Ich habe mich dagegen entschieden aus mehreren Gründen
Erstens, weil du halt ordentlich abdunkeln musst
Worauf ich eigentlich beim 0815 Fernsehen gucken, wenn ich es denn mal mache
Gar keinen Bock habe
Und ohne ordentlich abdunkeln funktioniert das mit Beamer nicht
Das ist eigentlich der hauptsächliche Grund
Weil ich, wenn ich Fernsehen gucke, dann eigentlich kurzfristig mal irgendwas anmache
Und ich finde ich einen ganz guten Kompromiss letztendlich
Achso, ja und natürlich HDR-Beamer weiß ich nicht was die mittlerweile kosten
Aber ich finde ich habe einen ganz guten Kompromiss und zwar
Leider war es da hell, als ich das aufgenommen habe
Letztens hat hier irgend so ein Dude drunter geschrieben, so nach dem Motto
Max, es ist 2018, warum filmst du deinen Monitor ab und nimmst nicht die Capture-Card auf?
Ich habe auch gedacht, sollte ich mal das Video angucken
Als würde HDR mit der Capture-Card ordentlich funktionieren
Als würde ich mein Ambilight und mein Setup mit der Capture-Card zeigen können
Na zumindest, ich habe einen ganz guten Kompromiss und zwar man sieht es hier leicht
Mal gucken ob man das irgendwo besser sieht
Ja hier sieht man es im Hintergrund, es ist leider nicht dunkel
Es ist leider nicht dunkel, aber ich glaube man sieht es hier ganz gut
Ich habe so ein Ambilight-Ding dahinter und es ist halt eine Wand
Die Wand hätte sich auch wunderbar für einen Beamer geeignet, keine Frage
Aber das ist eigentlich ganz cool
Das erweitert noch ganz gut das Bild über die Wand hinweg
Ich habe da einen Dreamlight RGB
Warum ist die Musik jetzt auf einmal so laut?
Nicht Dreamlight, Dreamscreen
Ja, wir gucken uns mal die Werbevideos davon an, das trifft es nämlich besser
What's going on?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung
Wobei, ich glaube der hat nicht, ich würde fast sagen, der hat nicht die richtigen Farbraum eingestellt
Weil es ist weiß und es ist lila, das passt nicht so ganz
Ja aber so ungefähr sieht das aus, man kann ja auch noch externe LED's dran anschließen wenn man will
Das ist wirklich ganz cool, das ist ein super Kompromiss finde ich
Der halt immer funktioniert
Kann er jetzt mal zeigen
Ja, genau und das ist wirklich ganz cool
Das geht auch wenn es nicht komplett abgedunkelt ist
Und das finde ich sehr angenehm, das ist wirklich nice
Da ist der Übergang zwischen Fläche vom Fernseh und von der Wand ist wirklich sehr fließend
Das ist wirklich cool
Und es ist halt kein Ambilight was eingebaut ist im Fernseh sondern zusätzlich
Die Installation ist total einfach, du klebst einfach hinten die LED-Streifen dran
Und machst die Dreamscreen-Box zwischen HDMI und Fernseh, also zwischen Ausgang und Eingang
Wie man das anschließt, ich kann es euch mal zeigen, das ist wirklich simpel
Die haben jetzt eine neue Box mit 4K und HDR
Ja, so wie in echt
Wobei was ich ja auch ganz cool finde ist, dass die Mutter wenigstens nicht mitguckt
Das ist auch ein Hauch von Realität, die Mutter guckt eher so, ihr geht mir auf den Sack
Ihr schreit hier rum halt die Fresse, ich will mal ein Zeug angucken
Die guckt übelst genervt die Mutter oder
Die Mutter guckt so, ey hätte ich dich nie geheiratet
Setup, ja irgendwo steht es wahrscheinlich drin
Wir gucken mal im Shop, im Shop sieht man es besser
Genau, Dreamscreen-Kits
Das ist das Kit ohne zusätzliche RGB, also ohne LEDs für den Schrank oder so
Einfach nur das für den Fernseh
4K, HDR-Kit
Genau, also das besteht im Endeffekt aus den LED-Streifen
Oh, der sieht mittlerweile besser aus, ich habe ja noch die alte Version
Die sah noch ein bisschen gefrickelter aus
Geht das auch am PC, klar
Du kriegst das schon teilweise billiger, musst mal gucken
Kann man den Dreamscreen, ich habe ihn damals direkt aus USA bestellt
Und ist natürlich direkt beim Zoll hängen geblieben
Okay, mittlerweile kann man das Ding auch
Ihr müsst ja mal auf einen Deal warten, also ich würde mir nicht die 300 Euro Version kaufen
Das ist total übertrieben
Ihr müsst ja mal gucken, wahrscheinlich für so 150, 200 Euro
Kommt man da wahrscheinlich schon hin
Also ich habe noch die alte Version, die sah, mal gucken ob die die überhaupt noch haben im Shop
Kits
Das HD-Kit, Do-It-Yourself-Kit
4K
Ne, das alte gibt es gar nicht mehr
Das alte gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr
Ihr könnt natürlich auch die volle Ladung kaufen, noch mit zwei Lichtern für nebendran
Aber prinzipiell ist es anschließend ziemlich einfach
Also ich muss sagen, bei mir sah das Zeug noch ein bisschen mehr gebastelt aus
Die haben anscheinend ihre Produkte auch verbessert
Du hast einen USB-Hub
Nicht ein USB-Hub, was laber ich denn
So ne Art HDMI-Hub
Wo halt auch die Logik drin ist
Hier schließt du im Endeffekt dein Output an
Also quasi hier ist bei mir das Nvidia Shield
Shield-TV dran
Und von da gehst du dann
Also hier kommt der Input vom Shield rein
Hier kommt auch die LEDs kommen hier auch rein
Und dann gehst du hier mit dem HDMI an den Fernseher ran
Fertig, das war's
Das war eigentlich ziemlich einfach
Geht damit noch
Jaja, das ist alles HDCP und funktioniert ohne Probleme
Damit funktioniert sogar Amazon Video 4K HDR ohne Probleme
Angeblich, ich kann bloß für Amazon
Für ohne HDR sprechen, weil meins noch kein HDR kann
Noch kein 4K HDR
Also mindestens 1080p normale Farben Amazon Video ist überhaupt kein Problem
Funktioniert
Es funktioniert sogar noch
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt, aber diese Steuerung
Vom Fernseher oder beziehungsweise
Über HDMI funktioniert auch noch
Also sprich, wenn ich das Shield-TV ausschalte
Dann schickt das über HDMI an den Fernseher
Dann befehlt zum Ausschalten und der Fernseher geht auch aus
Das funktioniert auch noch darüber
Also das Ding ist wirklich cool gemacht
Das ist wirklich nice
Also es ist nicht billig
Muss man halt aussehen
Ich meine, das kostet auch, wenn du hier guckst, was hat das Kram gekostet
Ah, irgendwie das volle Kit
Wenn du das volle Kit mit den zwei Scheinwerfern noch haben willst
Dann kostet es jetzt halt 340 Dollar
Da kommt wahrscheinlich noch Fahrt- und Versandkosten drauf
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich bezahlt habe
Aber ich habe glaube ich noch mal 60 Euro obendrauf bezahlt
Für alles zusätzliche, weil es ja auch im Zoll hängen geblieben ist und alles
Und über 150 Euro kostet dann auch noch Mehrwertsteuerung
Also es ist nicht billig
HDMI CEC, genau, das meine ich
CEC meine ich
Ja und Beamer war mir einfach zu aufwendig
Du musst komplett abdunkeln
Du brauchst die passende Wand, die hätte ich
Du musst den Beamer irgendwo hinstellen
Da hätte ich keinen Platz dafür gehabt
Da hätte ich mir quasi noch was an die Wand schrauben müssen, wo ich das Ding hin
Da muss es erstmal vorglühen und anwärmen
Und nicht vorglühen, aber erstmal warm werden
Ja also Beamer war mir zu aufwendig
Für jemand, der halt nicht sich auf den Sofa setzt und Filme
So quasi genießen will, da bin ich halt nicht
Ich mache wenn schon kurz was an und gut ist
Und klar gucke ich auch mal einen Film über Amazon
Aber dann nie so nach dem Motto
Ja jetzt auf Sofa setzen, noch irgendwie dunkel machen
Und ich mache halt einfach den Film an
Ich warte auch nicht bis 20 Uhr oder so
Ich mache einfach 18 Uhr einen Film an
Film angemacht, geguckt, ausgemacht
Wieder, keine Ahnung, einen Rechner-Stream angemacht oder so
Also ich bin nicht so der Fernsehtyp, der da lange drüben sitzt
Deswegen hat sich das mit Beamer für mich nicht gelohnt
Ja
Gibt es auf Amazon nichts Gutes heute
Also wir sind jetzt schon auf Seite 10
Bisher aber nix dabei
Ich geh mal kurz aufs Klo
Ich bin gleich wieder da
So, ähm, ja warum ich keine, also generell mache ich kaum Hintergrundbilder, weil ich
verwende meinen Desktop eigentlich so gut wie nie.
Mein Desktop ist eigentlich nur ein weiterer Ordner und der ist eigentlich auch immer
komplett voll mit irgendwas, weil ich ihn halt nie, ich gucke nie auf den Desktop, wozu?
Das liegt aber daran, dass ich unter Linux hauptsächlich arbeite mit i3 und ich halt
auch einfach gewöhnt bin, dass man keinen Desktop hat.
Kannst du einen Router empfehlen?
Ja, da hatten wir es doch gerade vorhin von, ähm, suchst du einen Fritzbox-Ersatz oder
suchst du wirklich einen Router?
Also irgendwas, was routen kann, viele Einstellungen hat, PoE eventuell noch kann oder suchst du
quasi einen Fritzbox-Ersatz, weil einen Fritzbox-Ersatz gibt es nicht, Fritzbox ist das Beste in
quasi ihrem Bereich von Features und Kompatibilität her.
Router, ja wenn du Router willst, nimmst du hier einen Mikrotik PoE, nimmst du den hier,
das ist für mich persönlich der beste Router preisleistungsmäßig und von Features her.
Diese High-End ASUS und Netgear Router, kein Fritzbox-Ersatz, könnte sein, dass sie das
sein wollen, ich weiß nicht, ob die zum Beispiel einen DSL Modem und Gelernstrainer haben,
wollen sie bestimmt sein, aber sind sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Der ist echt gut hier, wenn du wirklich einen Router suchst, kostet es 65€ oder so.
Kann PoE in, kannst du den mit PoE ver- ja hier sieht man es doch, aber er zeigt dir
noch ein bisschen das Ding.
Es sieht nicht hübsch aus, aber man muss einen Router auch nicht.
Du hast, wie du hier siehst, du hast RSFP-Port, du hast 5 Gigabit-Ports, einer wo du sogar
den kompletten Router mit PoE betreiben kannst, wenn du willst, overlay, ah, lol, und wenn
du den Spinetz-Teil betreibst, hast du hier auch noch ordentlich PoE-Out, ist in der
Fritzbox kein Router, eine Fritzbox ist unter anderem auch ein Router und so ziemlich 30.000
andere Sachen auch, ja, von NAS zu Internetradio zu Kameraserver zu Access Point zu Switch
zu Router zu VoIP zu Deck zu Fritzbox, das ist alles irgendwie, ja, was ist PoE, Strom
übers Netzwerkkabel, mal ganz billig gesagt.
PoE ist das bessere Diablo, das ist richtig, das ist, das kann man eigentlich fast nicht
bestreiten, dass das so ist, sag mal, läuft der gleiche Song schon zum zehnten Mal gerade?
Das lief doch schon 5 Mal jetzt, oder läuft das immer noch?
Was empfiehlst du für ein Access Point mit Switch, ne, da sind ja erstmal zwei unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe, ne, also Access Point, wenn es günstig sein soll, kannst du dir auch, also
im Prinzip, Access Point kannst du eigentlich fast alles nehmen, MikroTik hat ganz gute
und wenn man ein bisschen mehr ausgehen will, kann man sich die Ubiquiti ACU Pro Dinger
holen, diese runden blauen Teile, die sind auch ganz gut.
Was hältst du denn von den ganzen Ubiquiti Geräten, eigentlich nicht so viel bis auf
die Access Points, also ich meine, damit jetzt ihre Kameras und ihre komischen Security Appliance
Dinger und so diese haben, was Ubiquiti hat, sind gute, gute 10G-Switches und gute Access
Points, also ich hab nen Ubiquiti Access Point 2 und nen Ubiquiti 10G-Switch, die sind
beiden nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht solltest du das AFK-Klo auch zu deinem Overlay-Tool hinzufügen, das ist eine
sehr gute Idee, aber ich hab's jetzt ausgeschaltet oder, ja, preust einen Access Point, der auch
nen Switch indikiert hat, warum stöpselst du nicht einfach nen Switch dran, also was
spricht dagegen, kauf dir, wenn du sowas brauchst, kauf dir doch, kauf dir nen 15 Euro TP-Link-Switch,
kauf den 15 Euro TP-Link-Access-Point, stöpsel die zusammen und schon hast du nen Access
Point mit Switch.
Was ist 10G?
10 Gigabit Netzwerk, da hab ich den von Ubiquiti, diesen Switch hier, da, den da, hast du hier
12 Glasfaser-Ports und 4 Kupfer-Ports jeweils 10G, das Ding ist echt nice, das ist wirklich
ein, für den Preis und für den Feature ist das wirklich ein guter Switch, gibt's immer
noch nix wirklich Konkurrenzfähiges dazu und welchen Access Point, keine Ahnung, äh,
wie gesagt, ich hab, ich hab den, ähm, den hab ich, könntest du Ubiquiti nicht Ubiquiti
aussprechen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man die offiziell ausspricht, also so nen Teil
hab ich, der hat auch übrigens 2 Ports, also da hast du quasi auch nen Mini-Switch mit
dabei, wenn dir ein zweiter Port reicht, ist das ok, ja, ja der hat unten, man sieht's
leider nicht, weil die der Meinung sind, Bilder von Anschlüssen ist komplett overrated,
muss man nicht machen, hier, der hat 2 Netzwerkanschlüsse unten, wo du eigentlich nur einen brauchst,
aber den zweiten kannst du auch verwenden, falls dir den zweiten Netzwerkanschluss reicht,
ja, gehst hier zu deinem Router und da kannst du noch was zweites dran anschließen, aber
ganz ehrlich, ich würd mir einfach den Access Point und den Switch kaufen, wenn ich nen,
oder du guckst mal was Mikrotik hat, Mikrotik hat nämlich auch, ähm, die sind eigentlich
immer in Besuch wert, zu gucken, was die so haben, wollen wir hier mal gucken, Wireless
for Home Office, guck, die haben auch Access, die haben auch quasi Switches mit, äh, bzw.
eigentlich sind's Router, Router mit, mit WLAN integriert, haben sie auch, kostet ganze
20 Dollar, ja Mikrotik hatte irgendwelche Security Geschichten in letzter Zeit, ich
weiß nicht mal was es gewesen ist, aber gibt's schon, gibt's schon Updates, genau, irgendeiner
hat das Web Interface, ähm, gehacksworn, allerdings, wenn du das Web Interface ins
Internet stellst, ist eh schon Fail, ne, was ist ein Exit Point, hab ich Exit Point gesagt,
ich mein, mein Exit Point, ja ich rede heute ein bisschen undeutlich, weil mir immer noch
die Zunge wehtut, hab heute beim Zahnarzt angerufen, ich kann da wahrscheinlich irgendwann
die Woche noch hin, er hat jetzt erstmal gesagt, nächste Woche Montag, aber muss ich
mal nerven, mir ist unten in der Mitte ein Stück vom Zahn abgegangen und ist jetzt halt
relativ scharfkantig und irgendwie, ah, ist irgendwie die Zunge aufgeschnitten dran, Wut
Face und vor allem Zahnarzt, ne, nicht, nicht, falsch, den hier meine ich, Bypass Authentication,
ja ok, wenn man sein Management Interface ins Internet hängt, ist man aber irgendwo
auch selbst dran schuld, das macht man auch nicht sowas, Dojo Solve, die APU 2, ja, kann
man empfehlen, Problem ist, hat mir zu wenig Netzwerkports gehabt, es gibt allerdings
auch, ähm, wenn man selbst was bauen will und was günstiges sucht, kann man einfach
hier mal nach, ähm, Nutella? Warum steht da Nutella drin? Soll ich auf Aliexpress Nutella
kaufen? Fuck, ernsthaft, ähm, ähm, die haben auch immer so, so kleine billige, ähm, lüfterlose
PCs, wo man sich auch ganz gut einen Router mitbauen kann, wenn man will, wobei man halt
sagen muss, problemfreier und unterm Strich auch performanter, wobei das beim Traffic
im Heimnetz wenig relevant ist, ist immer so ein, so ein Fertigding. Stimmt es, dass
man seinen Ping mit verschiedenen Routern verbessern kann? Also mit Fertigding meine
ich irgendwas, was einen ordentlichen, ähm, Architektur hat für I.O., also nicht unbedingt
gerade x86. Stimmt es, dass man seinen Ping mit verschiedenen Routern verbessern kann?
Nee, kannst du nicht. Du kannst höchstens deinen Ping mit verschiedenen Routern verschlechtern,
wenn du dir da irgendwie so was dranhängst, was zu viel Magic macht. Diese ganzen Ping-Optimierungstools
basieren entweder auf billigen QoS-Regeln, die man überall selbst einstellen kann, oder
aber sie sind gepaart mit irgendwie so einem Gamer-VPN. Das kann ganz nützlich sein, aber
wahrscheinlich nicht für das, was die Leute verwenden wollen. Nämlich, ähm, wenn das
Server bei einem in der Region gibt, dann ist es immer am besten, du gehst direkt hin.
Ja, also guck mal, ich hab die Server hier bei mir in der Ecke, Besides Battlefield,
Call of Duty ist egal, die stehen entweder in Frankfurt oder in Köln. Das sind so eigentlich
die zwei Standorte, wo du hauptsächlich was stehen hast. Da hab ich, da hab ich eine Verbindung
hin von 5 bis 8 Millisekunden. Da muss ich, da kann ich nichts mehr optimieren. Irgendwann
ist mal vorbei. Diese komischen Gamer-VPN-Dienste, die es gibt, die lohnen sich eigentlich, wenn
überhaupt, nur wenn man irgendwelche asiatischen MMOs spielt, oder irgendwelche NA-MMOs spielt,
und der Provider eine nicht allzu vorteilhafte Route hat. Da kann das was bringen, ja, also
sprich, wenn man auf einem, sag mal, auf einem NA-Server WoW spielen will, und man hat da
irgendwie einen 500er Ping hin, und dann kann das sein, dass man mit irgendeinem Gamer-VPN
vielleicht einen 300er Ping hat, oder so, was es von unspielbar zu spielbar macht. Dann
hat das alles sinnvoll, aber da kann dir der Router wenig bei helfen. Ich weiß es nicht,
die ganzen Sachen, wenn du guckst, es kann auch Düsseldorf, ja doch, es kann Düsseldorf,
es kann wirklich Düsseldorf sein. Aber die ganzen Kisten, wo du guckst, steht meist
irgendwas von Cologne dran. Ja, dann wird es Düsseldorf sein. Ja, dann ist es mein wegen
Düsseldorf. Weiß ich nicht, da war ich noch nicht, was RZ angeht, in Frankfurt war ich
schon. In Parkour. Und der DZX auf der Hanauer Landstraße ist wirklich groß. Wobei ich bezweifle,
dass dort dieser aber direkt drinne steht. Das ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen teuer vom
Platz her. Ich hab da eine letzte Frage übersehen, was denn war, ich kann mal hochscrollen.
Habe mittlerweile einen, also der Buchhalter hat hier geschrieben, habe mittlerweile einen
Managed 5-Port-Switch von Netgear und absolut keine Ahnung, was ich daran managen soll.
Hab mir schon die Software und Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten angesehen, aber keinen Plan, hast du eine
Idee? Naja, wenn der Switch funktioniert und du nichts managen musst, dann muss ja nichts
zwangsläufiges managen. Mit Managed ist in der Regel eigentlich nur gemeint, dass du
dich in irgendeiner Form darauf einloggen kannst und Konfigurationen vornehmen, wenn du will,
wenn du willst. Das Managed bezieht sich eigentlich nur drauf, das Ding hat einen Web-Interface,
hat einen SSH-Login oder hat irgendeine Login-Variante, wo er was machen kann. Zum Beispiel kannst
du WLANs anlegen. Also wenn du sagst, ok, ich hätte gerne einen WLAN für mein PC und
der PC von meiner Schwester oder so hängen zwar am gleichen Switch, sollen aber nicht
im gleichen logischen Switch hängen. Dann machst du quasi deinen PC auf WLAN 5 und
den von deiner Schwester auf WLAN 15 und dann geht das nicht. Aber eigentlich musst du
da nichts managen, wenn alles so tut, wie du willst. Was hast du mittlerweile für ein
Handy? Ich hab immer noch ein iPhone 6. Ne, Managed musst du nicht, ne, ne. Du kannst
jeden Managed-Switch einstöpfen und einfach als dummes Switch verwenden, der nichts anderes
macht, außer zu Switchen. Halt alles im gleichen WLAN bzw. alles halt ohne WLANs. Oh, das ist
toll, Patrick. Das hätte ich wirklich gebraucht. Das ist nice. Für die alte Katze hab ich sowas
schon mal geholt und die hat sich nicht drauf getraut, weil es so wackelig ist. Aber was
ich meiner Katze geholt hab, hatte, was jetzt leider nicht mehr braucht, aber es hat immerhin
schon irgendwie noch mal zwei Wochen draufgelegen, war das hier. Das da. Das hab ich ihr geholt.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice. Ja, Patrick, die mussten wir einschläfern lassen am Freitag,
am Donnerstag. Ich hab gerade keine Katze mehr. Die erste war ja das hier. Warte mal. Das
war ja die erste. Das war original, Katz-FPS. Die gestreifte und das war die neue. Die hatte
ich aber ja erst seit April oder so. Sie hieß übrigens Barbie. Das hat ihr die Oma, die
sie vorher hatte, den Namen gegeben. Ich würde meine Katze nie Barbie nennen. Und die hatte
ich jetzt halt bloß, ich bin ein halbes Jahr oder so. Aber die war von Anfang an schon
krank. Man konnte es absehen. Und die letzten Monate hatte ich auch Nierenprobleme, hat
kaum was gefressen. Das war auf jeden Fall abzusehen. Das hat ein nicht sonderlich überraschend
jetzt getroffen, aber es ist halt trotzdem scheiße. Ja, und hier hab ich diesen Ofen
gekauft. Das ist wirklich ganz praktisch. Also so ein Strohkissen dabei, wie man hier
sieht. Ja, ungefähr so liegt. Meine Beine waren kleiner, die haben noch nicht so viel
Platz drauf gebraucht. Kauf eine neue. Ich kauf keine neue. Mensch, dann hol ich mir
irgendeine aus dem Tierheim. Ich seh es nicht einfach, warum man Katzen kaufen sollte, wenn
so viele im Tierheim hocken und quasi da verschimmeln. Na ja, zumindest ist es ganz praktisch. Das
schließt da an Strom an hier. Und drüber kommt so ein Strohkissen. Und es wird dann
halt, das musst du halt den ganzen Tag dran lassen, braucht halt auch nicht viel Strom,
dann wird er langsam warm und richtig warm halt hier in der Mitte. Und dadurch, dass
das Strohkissen drauf ist, ist es dann halt schön warm unten dran. Das riecht schon
nice. Noch besser als das hier. Das ist wirklich cool. Kosten die im Tierheim nichts, doch.
Aber billiger, wenn man irgendwie nach dem Preis gucken will, aber vor allem hilft man
der Katze, die ansonsten halt vergammelt. Also Tierheim wird der Sache auf jeden Fall
vorziehen. Vor allem muss man sich mal überlegen, es sitzen so viele ältere Katzen im Tierheim,
die keiner mehr haben will. Dann nimm ich lieber noch ein paar ältere. Ja, auch wenn
man nicht so lange dann quasi Spaß an der Katze hat, bzw. die Katze Spaß mit einem,
weil eigentlich ist man ja eher dazu da, um seiner Katze zu dienen. Und nicht, dass die
Katze Spaß mit einem, also die Katze hat eher Spaß mit einem als man mit der Katze. Ja,
aber wie viel zahlt man denn im Tierheim? Das ist bestimmt komplett unterschiedlich
von Tierheim zu Tierheim. Also ich habe glaube ich 200 Euro oder so, 150, 200 Euro bezahlt
dafür. Das war aber auch kein Geld für die Katze an sich. Das verrechnet die irgendwie
als Spende oder so. Machst du mal eine Roomtour von deinem aktuellen Setup, habe ich schon
ewig vor, aber dazu müsste ich erstmal meine ganzen Amazon-Kartos und Gedöns hier mal
rausräumen, dass es hier nicht mehr aussieht, wie als wäre ein Einbrecher drin gewesen.
Also die Katze jetzt, also hier, Barbie, Barbie der Name ist so schlimm, hab ich auch nie
gesagt. Die hätte nix gekostet, ich hab da 150 Euro noch gespendet für sie. Die hat
nix gekostet, weil es war allen Beteiligten klar, dass die Katze krank ist. Ich hab halt
gesagt, die nehmen sie trotzdem. Ich hab natürlich gehofft, dass es ein bisschen, dass es wieder
besser wird. Und was du da für Zeug, hab ich ja letztens schon im Stream erzählt, was
du da für Dinger unterschreiben musst, wenn du eine Katze holst. Was wollte ich eigentlich
auf Aliexpress, ach so ein Mini-PC. Ah Moment, Aliexpress gucken wir mal, ob es heute Sea-Wave
Door-Sensor gibt, ob es die wieder billiger gibt. Kann man nie genug von haben und ich
hab noch ein paar Türen hier im Haus. Vier Stück, das ist doch viel zu teuer. Ob, sind
nicht runtergesetzt. Hiervon hab ich ein paar, die haben damals irgendwie nur 10 Dollar gekostet.
Wohlgemerkt Free Shipping oder irgendwie 3,50 Euro Shipping. Shipping aus China ist übrigens
billiger als Shipping aus Deutschland in vielen Fällen, was eigentlich auch schon irgendwie
lächerlich ist. Und kam dann irgendwie nach 40 Tagen oder so an, hat einen ganzen Sack
voll Door-Sensors, wo hier einer 35 Euro kostet, irgendwie für 10 Dollar. Was können
die Sensoren? Da ist im Prinzip ein Magnet drin und du kannst damit gucken, ob eine Tür
offen oder zu ist oder ein Fenster offen und zu ist. Im Prinzip kannst du, wo die Sensoren
dran sind, das Ding löst aus, wenn die Sensoren auseinander gehen. Das kannst du quasi für
alles verwenden, wo du dafür einen Anwendungszweck hast. Hauptsächlich verwendet man es halt
für Fenster und Türen. Du machst die eine Hälfte quasi an den Rahmen, die andere Hälfte,
das ist klein, das ist wirklich nicht groß, machst du an den Rest vom Fenster und wenn
du dann aufklappst und die Tür aufmachst. Hot Cheese, jawoll. Übrigens beste, mal gucken,
ob es die Barbecue Sauce hier gibt, die ich immer hole, warte mal. Australia, Australia,
Australia. Sauce, Sauce, dieser beste Barbecue Sauce, sehr, sehr nice. Leider nicht reduziert
heute, aber die ist echt gut. Raw Sauce. Und ich habe es erst verkehrt gemacht, ich
so als Grillnoob habe quasi gedacht, drauf ziehe ich eine schöne Barbecue Sauce und
haue sie danach dran drauf, aber was ich nicht wusste ist, dass es eigentlich gar nicht
so gut schmeckt, wenn man die Barbecue Sauce quasi sich danach irgendwie auf Steak haut,
sondern richtig gut schmeckt das Zeug und das ist glaube ich, da ist auch die Zusammensetzung
irgendwie drauf ausgelegt. Richtig gut schmeckt es nur, wenn man es quasi auf das Fleisch
macht, bevor oder während es in Grill ist, dann schmeckt das viel besser. SSD Preise
gibt es gerade keine. Ich habe vorhin geguckt, es gibt gerade keine SSDs, Cyberbande, guck,
keine SSDs. Oder doch? Anscheinend doch. Fail Anzeige. Das ist glaube ich der typische
Amazon Debate. Ich glaube das ist der typische Amazon Debate, angeblich ist es ja hier von
190 Euro runter gesetzt auf 80 und ich könnte wetten, wenn wir danach jetzt mal auf Geizhals
suchen, sind wir nicht mal ansatzweise bei 180 Euro. Guckt bei MineFactory 76. Also wie
auch immer Amazon auf diese Preise kommt, das heißt selbst die krass runter gesetzte Cyber
Band der SSD ist bei MineFactory billiger. Das ist der übelste Debate. Und das muss
man eh immer gucken, weil einfach bei vielen Sachen die Preise komplett Debates sind auf
Amazon. Genau die hat bei der Markt an 490 Euro gekostet, das ist irgendwie so die Preisempfehlung
vom Hersteller. Also... Was das die MX500 ist drinne? Die ist aber auch nicht drinne
als das die Cyber Mandate ist. Übrigens nice, die ganzen Follows heute. Guck mal ob ich
noch irgendwie sehe wer alles am Start ist. Ich sehe ja leider immer die letzten paar hier
in dieser Übersicht. Dann haben wir hier am Start den Herbi 075 Granit Toss Weiß 55
Grasius Baumi 1337 Simpy Toxic und Rekuza. Mehr sehe ich leider nicht. Ich glaube da fehlen
dazwischen auch noch welche. Leute ich muss jetzt was futtern. Ich muss jetzt mal langsam
was essen. Ich habe nichts gegessen heute Abend. Oh Software Update iOS 12.1 ist verfügbar.
Later. Remind me later. Alter nervt mich rum. Taugt das neue Pokemon Game was? Wenn es
was taugen würde, würde es der Fabian wahrscheinlich spielen.
Gibt es heute noch Porgas? Nee ich esse jetzt was und dann ist Schluss.
Also 22 Uhr muss ich pennen. Muss morgen wieder früh aufstehen arbeiten. Ansonsten plus
noch ein paar Tage dieses Jahr. 1 2 3 4. 8 Tage muss ich noch arbeiten dieses Jahr dann
habe ich vorbei. Was? Max? Geine Sieß? Wie soll ich das genau aussprechen soll? Hat
ich geschrieben gegen diese Amazon Betrügereien kann ich jedem Kammel Kammel Kammel empfehlen.
Heißt wirklich so. Das ist so wahrscheinlich so ein Tracker wurde ja anzeigt was es bei
anderen Shops kostet. Wie hast du es hinbekommen, dass in der Taskleiste größere Felder für
offene Programme keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Wahrscheinlich irgendwo in den Taskleisten
Settings. Ach so das ist wichtig hier. Das muss man immer ausschalten. Weil wenn man
das einschaltet, dann hat man so ein Kack hier, wo man überhaupt nichts mit anfangen
kann. Also sprich wenn ich meine Programme nicht mehr sehen will, dann mache ich sowas
hier. Never ist gut, da wird es nie gekruppt. Video bleibt selber komplett frei. Jo. Ja das
habe ich mitgekriegt mit der Bombe in Frankfurt. Das habe ich mitgekriegt. In Frankfurt werden
öfters Bomben gefunden. Also aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg. Keine Arnele Geschichten oder so.
Aus dem zweiten Weltkrieg. Das habe ich mitgekriegt, ja. Ist der Interaction Fra 7, ist das der
auf der Hanauer Landstraße? Ne, oder? Ich weiß nur, dass der auf der Hanauer Landstraße
auch von Interaction ist. So, ähm, Leute ich werde jetzt was essen gehen. Ich hab
hier schon die ganze Zeit stehen, aber ich kann nicht labern und fressen dabei. Kann
ich euch ins Ohr schmassen. Ich werde jetzt was futtern. Übrigens eine Sache muss man
sagen, jetzt muss ich gerade die Dash-Buttons sehen. Wer denkt, ein Dash-Button für 5 Euro
ist vielleicht viel. Wenn die Dinger, ich habe es schon mal runter gesetzt, für 1 Euro,
dann ist das ganz gut. Ähm, die kann man umfunktionieren zu einem Button. Also, dass
der nicht mal nur Amazon-Dash-Button macht. Da gibt es ein Projekt auf GitHub. Amazon-Dash-Dash,
da gibt es ein paar Projekte. Da kann man quasi alles auslösen mit dem Amazon-Dash-Button
und nicht nur bei Amazon kaufen. Das ist ganz praktisch. Also, wenn man einfach nur
einen Button braucht, für sein Heimautomatisierungszeug oder sowas, zum Beispiel so ein, ich gehe
jetzt ins Bett-Button, kann man sich für 5 Euro dann ein Dash-Button hinlegen und sich
das GitHub-Projekt installieren und dann sein Heimautomatisierungszeug triggern. Also,
wie lange halten die? Naja, nachdem es WLAN ist oder die Batterie ist. Also, das batteriebetriebene
WLAN-Geräte halten in der Regel nicht lange. Deswegen schalten die sich aus und brauchen
immer relativ viel Energie erstmal zum Aufwachen. Also, ich denke mal, wenn du die regelmäßig
verwendest, werden die wahrscheinlich kein halbes Jahr halten. Eher kürzer, wenn du
die wirklich oft drückst. Wenn du die wirklich oft drückst, also mehrfach täglich, halten
die wahrscheinlich keine zwei Monate. Kann man die Batterie drin wechseln? Ich hab hier
zwar Dash-Buttons liegen, aber ich hab noch nie nachgeguckt. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich
weiß es nicht. Ähm, wartet mal. Ich hab hier irgendwo die Kiste mit dem Zeug drinne. Ich
muss mal gucken, ob hier auch die Dash-Buttons drin sind. Das sind keine Dash-Buttons. Ne,
keine Ahnung, kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken. Was ich hier für Zeugtränne hab? Das ist
so ein typisches Ding, was ich jetzt gefunden hab. Das ist so eine Dose mit Vago-Klemmen,
da kann man einfach Kabel zusammenklipsen, ohne dass man löten muss. Das ist so eine
typische Dose, wo ich wecken könnte, da würden die ganzen ASMR-Youtube-Typen übelst drauf
abgeben. Die würden dann so Videos machen. Oh, Tapping, Tapping, Tapping. Kennt ihr
das? Ich guck das ja teilweise ganz gern. Das ist schon echt entspannend. Oder dann
würden sie dann auch irgendwie so. Wir kippen jetzt die Dose nach links. Oh, die Dose kippen
nach links und jetzt wieder nach rechts. Oh man. Ich sag euch Leute, bei 300K Abos war
schon ein ASMR-Video. Da gehts ab. 300K Abos war schon ein ASMR-Video. Ich guck mir da auch
ein paar, also ich guck mir ja ganz gern die ein oder anderen ASMR-Videos an. Allerdings,
lustigerweise, hauptsächlich von Männern. Die meisten Mädels machen das so übertrieben.
Wenn man sowas guckt, dann guckt man das ja eigentlich zum Entspannen. Da sind dann
so viele Mädels, die dann irgendwie auch wieder halb, weiß nicht, ich kann mich dabei nicht
entspannen, wenn ich da junge, hübsche, halbnackige Mädels vor der Kamera sitzen hab in irgendeinem
Kino. Das ist für mich nicht so der Entspannen-Modus. Deswegen guck ich mir meistens, wenn ich mir
ASMR-Videos angucke, was von Typen an. Aber ich mein, auf der anderen Seite kommt nicht
vor ungefähr, dass die meisten neuen Channels in der Richtung einfach junge, hübsche Mädels
sind. Sebaro, was ist denn? Hast du eigentlich noch das HR-Tool getestet? Ach, nee, ich hab's
mit deinem Key noch nicht ausprobiert, aber den Key kannst du einlösen, den brauch ich
nicht, das probieren die dort aus. Das hat noch glaub ich keine Zeit für. Ich will auch
dein Windows-Key nicht verschwenden, jetzt für eine VM aktivieren, die ich danach wegwerfe.
Man kann die Dash-Button auseinandernehmen und die Batterien wechseln. Okay, gut. Gut,
Leute. Achso, Sebaro, ja, dann könnte ich das gleich sogar noch mal ausprobieren. Alles
klar, mach ich. Hab ich euch schon mal gezeigt, ich hab übrigens das Hardware-Tool noch ein
bisschen aufgebohrt. Kann euch grad mal was zeigen. Noch ein bisschen aufgebohrt. Ich
hab die Datenbank wieder gelöscht, deswegen steht da sonst nichts mehr drinne. Wir haben
jetzt bei Logs die Anzeige, ob der Key pending ist, also sprich, ob es den Rechner sich abgerufen
hat, aber noch nicht aktiviert und ob es aktiviert ist. Die Anzeige haben wir jetzt, das ist
ganz nützlich. Und wenn es aktiviert ist, steht dann die Mac da und das Datum, wann
es aktiviert wurde. Weil, wenn ein Rechner einen Key abruft und beispielsweise danach
aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht aktiviert, möchte ich mir den Key erneut wieder verwenden
können. Deswegen steht das dann hier drinne. So, und bei Stats hab ich jetzt noch ne Progress
Balken für verfügbare Keys. Also, beziehungsweise eigentlich müsste ich das sagen, wann gehen
die Keys aus, weil, ja, es ist ja nur ein Key drinne, das müsste eigentlich da stehen.
Da ist mir so, Achtung, gleich ist es voll. Ja, ansonsten hab ich ein paar Details verbessert,
das lädt jetzt noch ein bisschen schneller. Aber es ist immer noch ganz nice. Ja, und
die GIF-Render-Geschichte hab ich auch verbessert. Die können wir jetzt als, das ist im nächsten
Programmier-Stream, bauen wir das Meme-Tool, das, ähm, den DiodeX GIF-Renderer ein. Black
Mesa Accent-Trailer gesehen? Nee. Davon gibt's den Trailer? Oh, den müssen wir gleich gucken.
Danach muss ich aber was essen. Moment. Vorher erst noch mal. Das Meme-Tool ist aus, fuck.
Okay, fertig. Okay, Accent-Trailer, ähm. Black Mesa Accent-Trailer. Ja, das war's. Ja,
Black Mesa Accent-Trailer. Oh, nice. Da bin ich mal echt gespannt drauf. Achtung, wann
ist Release? Zweites Quartal noch. Hoffentlich, ob sich die jetzt dranhalten. Oh, das sieht
aber echt cool aus. Wo ist Shielob, oder wie das Ding heißt? Da ist sie. Oh, okay.
Rtx On. Wir haben gelernt, Spiegelungen gehen nur mit Rtx On.
Na, mal gucken, ob das jemals rauskommt. Wär schon geil. Also, wenn das rauskommt,
würde ich sagen, müssen wir nochmal komplett Black Mesa auf Im-Stream durchspielen. Sieht
sehr, sehr nice aus. Wirklich gut aus, gefällt mir. Gefällt mir echt gut. Gut, Leute. Ich
geh jetzt, ich geh jetzt was essen. Dann guck ich noch ein paar YouTube-Videos oder so,
dann geh ich pennen, 22 Uhr. Also, ich mach Schluss. Wir sehen uns morgen, oder die Tage,
mal gucken. Ich bin an letzter Zeit übelst regelmäßig am Stream sogar so weit schon,
dass ich jetzt quasi schon wöchentlich irgendwelche Mails krieg, so nach dem Motto Partner, Partner,
Partner, Partner. Wenn man jetzt wirklich fast, fast regelmäßig, weil das ist jetzt ja
nicht, kommt das zwar nicht so oft vor, aber doch schon in letzter Zeit relativ häufig
an die 200 Zuschauer haben
dann würde sich das doch
vielleicht mal anbieten
wir sehen uns
nächstes mal machts gut bis zum nächsten mal
zu
Jetzt aber gut.